can you repeat the great thing when i
interviewed you today for my own little
podcast
out there in your green room when i
entered your actual natural world what
do you mean great points you made about
bible true the three ways he's becoming
a dictator well so i said that the
republic has fallen uh and it's it's i i
did say this on my show earlier but for
those that didn't hear it so
there's there's there's it's hard to
know exactly where the line is when you
can say the the republic has fallen but
i think we can see it now and the way to
describe it is like a supernova you uh
it happens and we don't know for how
many millions of years until the light
finally reaches us oh look a supernova
happened 10 years 10 million so the
collapse happened and now we're
gradually the light is making its way to
us but it already happened so let me
explain exactly the borders are
collapsing
right so the first thing i'll i'll say
is keep in mind the borders but before i
get to the borders i'll say this and and
everybody who watches probably heard me
say something similar but
we are there there is no separation of
powers anymore joe biden violated uh the
separation of powers bypassing congress
by enacting the first eviction
moratorium which stood for like what was
like a year basically where the cdc says
you don't have to pay your rents but
most people only have one rental
property and they go bankrupt right
don't these are retirees so what what
biden did with that executive order was
effectively seized private property from
the public without any resistance at all
and no checks but so that bypass it's an
act of congress the supreme there's a
lawsuit the supreme court says biden
this is an illegal ruling you can't do
it so you know biden did
i'm going to reenact it again anyway
thus bypassing legislature twice
and the supreme court but he did it
again with the new osha rule and the
vaccine mandates once again the
sovereign has decreed and everyone in
this country not everybody most of these
businesses just go along with it which
makes it criminal bullying well let me
let me let me get to the the better
points what can you do
you as a client you as a peasant can
petition the courts and say i have been
wronged by the sovereign decree and if
the court agrees with you being wronged
they perhaps may tell the sovereign try
again and he does it again and they did
it again and what did the democrats do
the democrats are trying to use a budget
bill to give citizenship to non-citizens
now the senate parliamentarian says you
can't do that and what does the left say
the senate parliamentarian is is wrong
and it's tyranny i don't know i think
the senate parliamentarian does sound it
sounds crazy that someone can be like
you can't pass a bill but for the
democrats to be like instead of
negotiating with the republicans because
they're the minority and we don't have
to they use workarounds because we have
two distinct cultures in this country
fighting for centralized power and a
sovereign at the top who's ruling by
decree how do you know the republic has
fallen with all of that being said
illegal immigrants are walking back and
forth between the southern border for
carry out
when it can be so casual they can go to
get tacos and then walk back into the us
and then go back for tacos again the
next day there's no border there's no
jurisdiction the the the president is
ruling by decree in complete defiance of
of our laws our norms or traditions and
the left says the rights radicalized for
rejecting it while they support rule by
decree from cuomo you know from wolf
from gretchen whitmer from from newsom
and they and they re-elect newsome so
how do we counter that well i don't know
how familiar you are familiar you are
with uh james lindsay's work at new
discourses but he talks
a lot about um an essay by a guy uh
named herbert marcuse um and i think it
was called uh
was it uh
i forget the name of it liberal
tolerance or not not liberal tolerance
that was a book by jonah
jonah goldberg i think
repressive tolerance that's what it was
and essentially
um
it's it's the thought process that
the left generally says that anything
that is done
by people of the left is acceptable and
they'll make excuses for it and the
right anything that's done by the right
has to be
shut down even before there's any action
taken so even conversations about what
would be considered right-leaning ideas
those must be shut down and anything
that the left does that's why you saw
all last year antifa and and the riots
that were going on throughout the us the
whole of the liberal media and stuff was
making making excuses mostly saying it's
okay because it was it was it was from
the left mostly peaceful and then yeah
exactly and then anything that the right
does
is made to seem as
terrible as possible and and that's part
of why anything that donald trump did
got enormous amounts of criticism
january 6 is a great juxtapose because
that was wrong what happened a few
people got out of hand i said it was
wrong day one but then they're like
saying whoever says demonstrations are
peaceful and go out and harass people go
out and attack them they said that and
then i'm there trying to stop people and
the left are putting bounties out to
have me arrested that's right that's
cuomo yeah chris cuomo on cnn right who
says his protest got to be peaceful and
that dude was like yeah it's the first
amendment
but maxine waters had said the same
thing go out and harass uh politicians
and go to you know go and harass them
when they're eating or whatever and that
has always been
minimized and
said oh people say oh it's okay or it's
not that big of a deal or they make
excuses that book that was in defense of
looting
all that stuff has been all of this is a
pattern that's undeniable that's that
makes it very clear that if you are
of a left-leaning uh opinion or if
you're in service to left-leaning goals
it is okay whatever you want to do it's
there you're not going to get criticism
you're going to have the vice president
raising money to help bail you out so
here's the question that's what come on
where does that go then
why is the establishment and the big
corporations funding that move what are
they planning to do what are they
wanting out of this
i think that that really what it boils
down to is it's the easiest path to
uh authoritarian some type of
authoritarian control or more power to
the federal government we've got the
largest government in human history and
you if you think that the government
isn't interested in affecting what
you're allowed to think
because that's what they're that's what
they want to destabilize things and have
a limited civil war so then they crack
down on everybody
not only that but you look at look at
what happened with with nicki minaj
recently right so she says things that
are either off the wall or wrong or
whatever and the white house is reaching
out saying we'll have someone why on
earth would the world be so afraid of
somebody having free speech and of of
why would they be why would they
make time for
someone that has a bad opinion or a
wrong opinion that they'll actually have
the white white house reach out to them
obviously
it's because she throws a wrench in the
narrative that they're trying to promote
but the idea that the white house is so
interested in trying to control what
people think it's very un-american and
very dangerous it's really dangerous i
agree totally it's very very dangerous
and you brought this up before and and
suddenly before we came up here
and this is something i didn't even know
about
because i read a lot of news and i heard
people saying did you hear how certain
people at my office like a week ago alex
talk about how facebook they're like
handed me piles of papers and i was busy
didn't read it how facebook has five
plus million people that are that live
under other rules than the other three
billion people that are on there so you
told me i looked it up there's the wall
street journal how there's a secret
elite who they have speech but nobody
else does
yeah we gotta hear from uh cnbc facebook
shields millions of vip users from
standard moderation protocols they would
have to
if if uh you know we we we've been
talking a lot about tech behind the
scenes because they can override the
sensor because they have their own
platform well so it's if you want an
outcome if you want to control for an
outcome then it can't be truly random so
we were talking about like lotteries
so lottery games scratcher tickets
they're not random they can't be so
there has to be an algorithm an
underlying algorithm because if if you
want to control for the outcome and make
sure only x amount of people win so you
retain more money than you spend it
can't be random sure the house always
wins in the end so when it comes to
facebook and guarding the vips it's
really simple
they need a certain set of political
discourse they deem acceptable the
controlled outcome but of course these
people are going to say things that are
breaking the rules which is why on
twitter it's very obvious on twitter the
left breaks the rules over and over and
over again but it's acceptable so
twitter is doing the same thing facebook
does when we learn that facebook as vip
users should i be surprised it was what
three almost over three years ago i
showed vajayagate and jack dorsey
themselves the antifa account that was
like go here and do these things and
they were like we're not taking it down
like they left it up they they banned
people who responded to it but the tweet
from the left calling province was
allowed to remain and isn't that the
ultimate form of bullying when you've
got big corporations with paramilitary
groups up firebombing things and then
they tell people that aren't even i'm
not even thinking of myself as a
conservative i don't think you do is
kind of a what mainline kind of populist
liberal journalist and then you look at
them and they're all wrapped in this
mantle they control everything and
they're going to keep you safe while
they've got factories with suicide nets
around them and it's just it's just it's
preposterous
and then the cnn's and the new york
times says i should be banned for stuff
i've said out of context but they
purposely lie about wmds and then
millions of people die from starvation
there's two things to consider
uh two potentialities
if it's true that there's a cabal that
has as much power as they do and they're
running things for a specific reason why
would this show be allowed to exist
well that's because still a lot even
with establishment or fro or pro free
speech and this is a process the last
time i was here you actually taught me
something really smart and if you go
back to that dialectic you were
discussing about how there's a wheel and
how the reason you're being left alone
right now is because they haven't moved
the wheel
yet until you're not acceptable and then
it's the next group and the next group
so i was the guy
four years ago they taught us has got to
be banned and then and and then you know
down the road it'll be you and that's
why you're smartly building your own
infrastructure your own plan joe with
spotify do kind of the same thing i've
done the same thing with man.video which
they've banned that link so it's free
world news dot tv and and so that's
really the renaissance is always moving
away from the empire trying to set
something up free or it's always free
for a while and then we become what we
ran from
yes so the other point i was going to
say is
that
well so there's actually i'll say
another point on that but i was gonna
say there's two things one is
why would they allow this to happen well
it's it's one potential potential answer
is as i described it to you last time
for those unfamiliar there's a wheel and
you've got right wing center right
centrist center left and left
and when i started they called me left
wing even with the same opinions i have
now like saying like i like universal
health care i think there's problems
with implementing it i'm pro-choice my
political opinions are relatively the
same then all of a sudden they started
calling me a centrist now they're
calling me right wing
you're you've been banned steve bannon's
far right tucker carlson's now far right
eventually the wheel will turn again and
i'll become you know far right and then
once that happens they just they lop off
the one side and then it's nazi at the
end but the other
the other potentiality is
uh i don't know i don't know the quotes
from i don't know if it's michael's
michael mouse's quote if uh if they were
winning the propaganda wouldn't be
necessary oh i totally agree listen they
can't do too much and turn us all
against them and that's already kind of
happening so that's the real answer and
there's also different power structures
in the elite there are billionaires of
people out there that aren't tyrants and
they believe in america so it's really a
handful of really ruthless select
corporations
that
klaus schwab used to run the bilderberg
group and i remember it was until 10 11
years ago the media would even admit
bilderberg group existed people say alex
that's the weird thing and then he went
in yes davos which is the public arm of
that and he used to run the u.n
biological diversity system so he's
really the head of the un program
and so it's a corporate takeover through
fake leftist ideas the crazy thing to me
is that during occupy wall street
bilderberg was a conspiracy theory yes
and then a few years later it was like
ah boulder bilderberg who cares you know
it's whatever well they got smart
instead of just denying it existed
because we i mean i remember the new
york times like 12 years ago we were
meeting in chantilly virginia bilderberg
we stayed in the hotel till they closed
it the king of spain got there they
saluted him i got out and there were
marines they're guarding and playing
clothes they flipped out that
helicopters secret service so they went
to my hotel threatened me all this stuff
it was insane uh pulled a fire alarm on
us said we did it at the other hotel we
were staying at did it one at the one we
were there it's a long story in the new
york times
said alex jones was in a field in
virginia imagining helicopters and men
with sunglasses i put out a film called
in game that showed all the footage in
multiple countries took me four years to
make in europe and canada and then in
the us put the film out and they're
literally the new york times saying
jones is insane having a full-on
hallucination at a chantilly virginia
conference hotel okay so i mean i have i
mean i'm seeing the king of spain i'm
getting video of of of the queen of the
netherlands at the video okay
and then they're saying it doesn't exist
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 p.m where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you